our technician took another job like
that's a very difficult position to fill
I'm not really capable so we got a young
hungry dude that just loves bikes loves
people wants to learn but that's put me
like 50 decrease so I'm like
operationally like 50 there it's a real
lesson that I try to tell everybody if
there is a mission critical employee
within an organization in a small
business one must at all costs have a
backup and or be mentally prepared for
six to 12 months to have to eat a whole
lot of crow and deploy three to seven
more hours a day that they likely don't
have it's one of those two that's
exactly where we're at let's make sure
we don't do that again so even as you're
training up this kid train up another
kid or train up yourself one thing I
tell everybody is the reason I'm always
cool as a cucumber is because I can do
everything in every business I have all
of them I can bring up people at the
register of Wine Library I know how to
do the marketing and strategy I can make
the videos if you're running a business
right now and you're listening and you
can't do everything absolutely have a
backup and probably start the process of
learning how to do it or You're
vulnerable